[Music]
to anyone who says i'm too young or
girls can't do it i would say come watch
a monster jam event watch me compete and
watch me win
[Music]
i'm rosalie raymer the world's youngest
professional female monster truck driver
when i first sat in the seat of a
monster truck i was 11. i started
competing at age 14
and i've been competing ever since i
could drive a monster truck before i
could drive a car on the road
i'm studying mechanical engineering at
georgia tech and i'm working on making
the monster truck of my dreams i'm
working on lowering the center of
gravity of the moss truck so that has
better handling and more capabilities
when we're out there on the field
competing
first i got an idea about how i want to
improve a monster truck
then i put some of my ideas down on
paper in my sketch pad i get to put that
into the computer so i can work with it
on a higher level and i get to 3d print
it
having a technical mind is definitely an
advantage on the field i know exactly
how my truck works and it allows me to
read how it's doing on the track
i can fix anything that's wrong with my
truck
wildflower is the first truck i got to
help build putting that pink those big
flowers on my truck that really shows
who i am and i'm proud of that
and i hope that that makes little girls
who do love princesses and who do love
flowers more open-minded to the world of
big trucks and machinery and mechanical
engineering
i'm proud of who i am
i am a woman i drive big trucks
[Music]
you